maybe this is a good place to ask uh in
working closely with Donald Trump what
in your sense looking into the mind of
of the man uh what's the biggest
strength of uh of Donald Trump as a
leader I would say his
unpredictability I think that as a
leader he's um he consumes a ton of
information he doesn't like to be
managed or have his information filtered
so he'll speak to a lot of people to
draw his information himself uh he's
very pragmatic I don't see him as
terribly ideological I see him as
somebody who's about results I think he
wants to deliver results um and I think
ultimately I mean he he's an incredible
fighter he's he's a big counter puncher
uh but he also wants to get along with
people and that's probably the biggest
surprise that people found with him I
mean you know you look at even
situations like uh I would always tell
tell people if you disagree with him
don't go on television and criticize him
just pick up the phone and call him and
go see him and he'll talk to you about
it he may not agree with you but again
that's what Kim Kardashian did when she
had a case of clemency with a woman
Alice Johnson that she felt strongly
about we went through the case I
wouldn't have had her call if I didn't
think it was a legitimate case so we
spent about eight months uh quietly
working through the case working through
the details to make sure that it really
was a worthy case um I brought it to
president Trump said you know she'd like
to come meet with you to talk about this
case and he said how come in so she came
in we went through the case and
president Trump ultimately granted the
clemency to Alice Johnson who was a a
woman who was accused of being part of a
drug ring uh she had a basically a life
sentence uh for doing it she'd served 22
years in prison while in prison I mean
she's basically was a grandmother and
she um she was you know putting on the
prison plays she was mentoring you know
young women in prison somebody who again
there's always a risk but by and large
had a very very very low risk of of
committing a crime in the future and
then it goes back to the notion of Are
We GNA judge people by the worst
decision they make in their life and so
president Trump uh was willing to Grant
the climate scene and went and I think
that it just goes to the notion of like
maybe this goes back to his
unpredictability in a positive way which
is if you go sit with him and you make
your case he'll hear you he'll listen to
you and he's not afraid to act and he's
not afraid to be controversial which I
think is a good thing so from a foreign
policy point of view in particular his
unpredictability just meant that
everyone was always on their back foot
people were afraid to kind of cross
America and what I would tell people who
don't like Trump is I would say think
about how crazy he's making you and and
his enemies you know he did that to the
enemies of America and um and yeah so he
was a very very strong president and I
think did a great job so and some of
these agreements I've been talking about
and and speaking with leaders how do you
think the unpredictability helps so in
all the agreements that I was
negotiating I wasn't doing it as a
principal I was doing it on behalf of
President Trump and people knew that I
had access to president Trump and they
knew that you know I could say you may
say this that we don't like but I'm G to
have to take it back to him and then
we'll see what he does and one of the
biggest instances was on the usmca trade
deal where um that deal happened because
Mexico was legitimately concerned and
smartly so that President Trump was
going to impose tariffs on the car
industry which would have been
decimating to their economy and by the
way he was ready to do it we were
holding it back from doing it with every
ounce of strength that we could so it
wasn't a bluff I mean that one was
actually real but they were smart to
read that it was real and ultimately we
created a great uh win-win deal um tell
you a funny story just popped into my
mind from from the tariffs is we did
also we used a 232 National Security
exemption to protect our steel industry
and we put tariffs on steel and aluminum
and again I I thought about this cuz we
also negotiated them with Canada and
there was a very funny phone call where
Trudeau is calling uh Trump and again
they got along you know decently well
and um Trudeau's calling saying you
can't put National Security tariffs on
us in Canada you know we're we're we're
your NATO Ally we we fought Wars with
you we do military together and Trump
says Tim didn't you burn the White House
Down in 1812 and TR say that was the
French no it was the Canadians
and so it was just you know like I said
he's always keeping everyone on their
toes yeah and um but he was he he he he
wasn't a he took very calculated risks
and like I said you know everyone was
outraged all the time with everything
but if you look at his body of work
people said if he was elected he would
start World War III meanwhile We
inherited a world filled with Wars no
new Wars right three years he made peace
deals no new Wars he was tough he was
strong people respected him he built
relationships and uh got trade deals
done got peace deals done the economy
was rocking his bodyw work I think was
pretty strong as
president